[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to
GameSpot's coverage of e3 2018 we are
rolling through all these amazing demos
I'm Mike McCarty I'm gonna be here all
week with Lucy James hey and if you're
just joining us we got to check out a
couple games already dying light too and
spider-man and now something I'm excited
for as well we're gonna check out
Assassin's Creed Odyssey we're here with
Jonathan Dumont from Team hey how's it
going hey good Sweeps gonna Assassin's
Creed twice now in press conferences
with that Ubisoft and then or maybe I'm
just thinking no no we just showed you
the Ubisoft gone yeah yesterday and that
with their big reveal of the game so
what's it like showing it off now oh man
they was cool to be on the stage and
represent what the team has been working
on we've been working on it for three
years
like really like intensively and man it
felt great to come out there and just
show it to the world so this is the team
that worked on the syndicate it's a
similar most of the team is the team
from syndicate but we you know I also
have other studios that helps us around
the world nine Studios across the world
that helped us make these big fantastic
games so I'm sure well we're about to
dive into like nitty-gritty stuff with
Sanskrit Odyssey I'm curious obviously
there was a year off in the release
cycle before origins came out what's it
like is there any was there any
hesitation on the teams part and Ubisoft
or did you know right when origins came
out you're like we we have our energy
back we're ready to start going yearly
well we've been working on it for three
years yeah in at the same time as origin
so we knew what they were doing we were
onboard with what they were doing it was
amazing game origins was great and then
the layer that were putting on top of it
it's just like pushes it into a big RPG
pushing choice at the center of the
experience really taking you into a
fabulous Odyssey and to ancient Greece
so ancient Greece being an amazing
setting for Assassin's Creed some say do
you choose ancient Greece we chose
ancient Greece yes yeah we chose it
because you know it is a wonderful
cultural background and we learned quite
a bit about you know philosophy
democracy and all those things and at
the same time you have culture on one
side and and the Peloponnesian War on
the other side which is perfect for us
if you want to explore the world as a
mercenary and choice being at the center
of the game we want you to conduct your
own moral code in that game so
you choose to be good or bad or
compassionate or a little bit of a
douche at the same time so you know you
can do all of that so can you talk about
how like you're pushing really hard into
RPG territory you were just telling us
before the show that you work for seven
years on world of warcraft yes yes
there's a lot of RPG influence origins
slowly started to introduce that but it
sounds like Odyssey is just going all
out on the yeah what so there's a base
from origin but we're pushing it much
further so just a gear system the gear
system is you have five pieces of gear
you can assemble they all have stats
depending on what your specialization
that you want to do over top of that we
can engrave special abilities on top of
those those weapons and gear slots and
we have put on top of the combat a new
totally new way of customizing your
playstyle
so you map your own abilities to create
your own fight play style or stealth
play style or marksman play style and
the other thing that we did put in is
dialogue so and your journey is based on
your choices and yes you'll get an epic
tragic big story and then you'll make
choices that will give you different
endings and different relationships with
characters as well what I like is that
it's not explicit the you don't really
know the consequences of your choices
immediately and some of the the gameplay
stuff I've been watching is like it can
feedback way later when you're not
expecting it sometimes so sometimes you
have short term medium term long term so
you can have like I'll give you an
example this person wants you to get a
sword and you know you find the sword
and you come back and said did you find
the sword they say you can add the lie
options no we didn't find it and then
you keep it for yourself there's a there
could be an immediate consequence for
that or you know like you give it back
and then you get a big reward and or the
medium medium term like putting in not
points but you know like stake into
relationships and see where those goes
and then big impacts to the end of the
games which I won't spoil here so so
what were some games you looked at for
that kind of inspiration I mean
obviously that's been a pillar of RPGs
since RPGs were a thing but like my our
friend Michael when he went up to play
the game he came back saying it reminded
me The Witcher and the way that Lucy was
describing almost like these unforeseen
consequences that will just pop up later
when you're least expecting it
I don't know did you look at the Witcher
or what kind of RPGs recent RPGs did we
played a bunch of games because we're
game fans like everybody so we we get
inspired by everything
there's not one specific game that we
looked at and said we want to do that we
wanted to do our own Assassin's Creed
RPG but the the thing with the choices
is we don't want to overwhelm the
players were choices choices but I have
a fun you know experience just like Oh
giving them tough choices things to
think about and then the consequences
can surprise you or you can anticipate
them so that's really what we wanted to
do I'm also curious how origins was you
know like the earliest in the chronology
last year when it released but Odyssey
is going before that we are oh people
are curious like maybe this is telling
the Templar origin story or how are you
like making an assassin's Creed game if
it's supposedly before the assassins
well origins the thing is our franchise
as many things to explore the first
thing is history right ister ii has
always been something that we take care
of and really research when we're doing
our our games the other leverage we have
is the continuation of a present-day
story so it is a continuation of origins
in the present day and our brand has
first sensation which are in
explanations to the gods and stuff like
that and we really tapped into that for
our game so don't have Templar
necessarily an assassin's but we do have
that at the at the foundation that
battle between chaos and order or
freedom and order that is at the heart
of the game as well and you know
reflecting on Greece people questioned
everything Socrates a little bit of pain
in the ass as well in the game so
putting that into that I want to think
about this order and chaos for myself
and you know sort of steer it where you
want to go so it is a perfect setting to
explore those concepts with choice at
the heart so obviously as is key to
Assassin's Creed games you have to have
the historical figures we've grown to
love so many of them
have been reinterpreted for the games
who are the big names that we will be
seeing in Odyssey so I'm not going to
talk about all of them because at once
there's some that are pretty surprising
the cool thing is that since we switched
a dialogue system it allows us to not
just have like four or five hours of
cinematic but go for 30 hours of
interactive dialogue so you can have
deep dives with Socrates very pleased
Apocrypha is the the the founder of
medicine so modern medicine medicine
existed but so it allows you to really
have relationships with those characters
that you couldn't do before right we we
can spend a lot more time there are
other historical characters there's a
few surprises that I'm not gonna talk
about because there's got to say whoa
you know that's really cool but really
thinking about what is classical Greece
an ancient Greece for for Assassin's
Creed II so watching naval combat right
now and we were just mentioning it when
I first heard about the game and I saw
it on Ubisoft conference I was thinking
to myself this looks like they took
origins and black flag and mesh them in
a really awesome way does that hold any
weight well it was not the intention but
looking at at the agency and you know we
want you to live a tragic Odyssey true
you know like true true ancient Greece
the boat is you know is the thing right
so it has the similar things as black
flag in the sense that unique can
upgrade your ship you can customize your
ship but it is Greek warfare so ramming
cleaving shooting arrows fires torches
you can also you can assault board and
then the biggest difference with us is
that your crew you can be recruited to
the world everybody pretty much
everybody in the game is recruitable so
you can customize your crew by all that
guys super strong and you sneak up and
then you you know put him down and then
give him a second chance and I said come
on man you can join my troop so you can
have your own unique crew you could be
playing the game you know for hundreds
of hours and then have different
feelings are there gonna be shanties
though they are songs on the boats thank
God and they're all in ancient Greece so
it's really cool and we do have a few
things that
I'm not gonna say cool stuff so the fact
that it's a role-playing game obviously
there's a lot of focus on who the next
protagonist is gonna be an Assassin's
Creed games now you have Alexios and
cassandra yes what's it like writing
protagonists for an RPG as opposed to
like this heavily scripted traditional
assassin's creed so they do have a
personality not an empty bucket that we
you know like just make your own
adventure with them so they do have a
personality their Spartan they're you
know like they're tough and everything
but we the approaches is different
because we want to if there's questions
we want the player to answer those
questions through their character so
it's really a different way of writing
we we staffed up our big team of writers
and we iterated on it so that we do get
the a good feeling about it but it's
really making when you do have a
decision to make setting it up in the
writing it's sometimes it's tough but
you know it's really it's really an art
to like now make a choice but also you
what having the choices in with the
excellent Cassandra we wanted them to be
able to express themselves as lying
romance option as well so that you know
you write that those things and if the
characters the players are interested
they can dive into that as well so I was
gonna say let's talk a little bit about
romance options because that's brand-new
and very exciting so what's it gonna be
like is it going to be immediately
apparent which characters you can and
can't romance what are the branches
gonna be like is there like a definitive
relationship status that you get enjoy
it's more of a handful of romance
romance able characters so you'll you'll
figure it out you know fairly quickly
when you say okay that that person is
laying there yeah and then you know like
some some relationships are short term
like real life and then some are a
little bit less you know medium term so
it's much more of a fun adventure and
then you never know what you're gonna
find on an island and their region so
you're gonna find people that are
interested in you and then it's up to
you to decide what are some of the core
pillars that you went into Odyssey like
assassin's creed obviously is a
long-running franchise since about 2007
2006 it's escaping me right now but what
were some of the pillars of Assassin's
Creed you knew you wanted to keep intact
yeah outside of like bringing it into
RPG territory intact well there's quite
a bit if you played origin you're gonna
see that we still have stealth and we
you know really put a lot of stuff on
stealth the new abilities on stealth and
refined some of the mechanics we like
the long range that was established in
origin as well the combat is the base
combat that we put a lot on top but you
know you can recognize those pillars
navigation of course you know and then
if you take a look at what we've done
with Nevada you can feel that experience
true novel as well history has always
been at